hey friends I'm Ilana and welcome it to
my channel this is the first video I've
made in like three months now for months
now I've been getting questions at this
point every day about why I'm not making
videos what happened to my YouTube
channel there's one that I screenshotted
because it was so ridiculous
and I can't believe she would abandon
her fans after all we did for her like
it means nothing that we made her Korea
because he has a headache what a [ __ ]
game ago thought just like all the rest
to that man and people who have shown
similar aggression just get just leave
just get out here but to the people have
been supportive and that is the
overwhelming majority of you thank you
I've got a lot of kind messages a lot of
tweets or comments from people who said
other people and their families have
dealt with chronic fatigue and I do
actually appreciate that it is nice
knowing that I'm not alone and that
other people relate to this because like
I said in my previous video the illness
that I've had is one that to a lot of
people is invisible so yeah everyone
who's said kind things thank you but I
do want to make this video to answer the
question have I quit YouTube permanently
am i coming back I was very sick for a
good three or four months and I have
been getting better
I do feel a lot better but I did want to
sort of approach my come back to making
content very slowly because I didn't
want to overwhelm myself because I think
I have been doing that at work honestly
I'd have a week where I felt bad and
then I would work double hard the next
week and skip lunch breaks and stay late
and do whatever I could and then I think
that was just putting me in this repeat
pattern of then feeling bad again
because I was pushing myself too hard
when I needed that time to recover but I
was like well I'm not tired so I should
just do everything like normal I was
also kind of screwing up the balance of
like not enjoying my life enough like it
bummed me out that when I had spare time
I was thinking about like I should try
and make a youtube video I should stream
instead of being like no I've been lost
in bed for a long time like whole of
December I was just asleep or in bed not
really moving and I think that I needed
the time to get my life back as an
individual because I felt like I had
missed a lot of it to be honest and also
I started DJing at a regular place in LA
I'm not gonna say where it is cuz I just
don't want to have that be public I
guess I just want that hobby to myself
kind of if you find me I'll buy you a
shot but otherwise secret but I started
doing that and I didn't want to just
bite off more than I can chew all at
once and go straight back into making
YouTube videos and streaming I did also
stream last week I decided to keep it
just to twitch and I only stream for
about an hour and it didn't announce it
anywhere just because the same thing I
didn't I don't want to overwhelm myself
too soon and that's basically the answer
to the question have I stopped making
YouTube videos completely did I quit
YouTube 100% because a lot of people
seem to think that I have done that or I
have made the call to do that
yeah there were some people who were mad
at me for not making a video saying that
I had quit which was not the plan no I
totally intend to come back to making
content I can't say how regularly
because this is the thing that I need to
do based on my life and how I feel and
what I'm doing but ideally at some point
I will slowly work my way up back to
making one video a week and streaming
maybe a couple of nights a week but I
just don't want to make any promises
that I can't keep because hey that puts
pressure on me to have to do the thing
and if I can't I'm just gonna feel like
[ __ ] and I'm gonna go through this cycle
again and I think I need to be a lot
more careful than I have been and then
be I don't want to disappoint anyone so
I don't want to make any promises that
are overly ambitious and then have my
audience be upset with me when I can't
keep those promises for reasons that are
out of my control also I got in a car
accident last week a lot of people been
asking about that again everyone's very
considerate so thank you that's got a
wisdom tooth removed like even when I
was starting starting to feel better
which was about a month and a half ago I
had to get my wisdom teeth out and then
I got in a car accident that was last
week I had a concussion concussion
sucked man I couldn't look at bright
lights I was trying to play rage too and
the first time that I tried I had to
stop and I couldn't and then I tried to
watch Game of Thrones and I couldn't I
couldn't look at my phone
it sucked that's okay now I think I'm
still a little bit headachy some
mornings and I did sort of throw up one
day this week that I think is still
related to the concussion a week later
for the most part that's okay but I have
whiplash my neck and my shoulders hurt
but again I'm just trying to you know
pace myself hopefully bad [ __ ] stops
happening to me but me to come back now
seems like a good time because III is
very close and you guys know so I'll
probably make some content surrounding
that hopefully cuz it does make me
really excited and I always really want
to talk about it so I'm thinking I'll do
that I will have a room to a video go
off my channel as soon as I get my new
PC which I'm expecting in the next ten
days this apartment is pretty rad it's
small because of course it is because
I'm a single woman living in an
expensive city but it sure is a [ __ ]
nerd cave I have one two three four four
TVs
if you include this monitor what's that
Windows Firewall you say it's BOTS and
features of Windows Explorer but Wow
what I'm saying yeah I have like four
screens in here and I only have one room
because it's the studio so I describe
this apartment as if a 12 year old boy
had money look forward to while seeing
it I just had to restart my camera
because my memory card got full because
I forgot that I'm supposed to check that
when I start making videos because it's
been so long so thank you guys for
bearing with me no I have not quit
YouTube forever
and abandon my audience and not told you
that I was doing that I promise if I
were ever going to actually quit that I
would I know it's that but yeah thank
you to everyone who's been so
understanding while you know YouTube
isn't my full-time job and I've never
pretended to be a full-time youtuber I
understand that if you provide people
entertainment or whatever else it is if
you take that away that it sucks for
those people so there's a balance there
and I get that I think that's it all
right everyone I'm Alana and I will see
you guys next time
buh-bye